let's say i have this matrix b here and
i want to know what the null space
what the null space of b is and we've
done this multiple times but just as a
review the null space of b is just it's
just all of the x's
it's just all of the x's that are
remember it's all the vector x's that
remember of what one two three four five
that are members of r
five
where
b
the my matrix b times any of these
vector x's is equal to 0. that's the
definition of the null space i'm just
trying to find the solution set to this
equation right here and we've seen
before that the null set
the null set of the reduced row echelon
form of b
is equal to
is equal to the null set of b so what's
the reduced row echelon form of b and
this is actually almost trivially easy
so if we just let me just take a couple
of steps right here
if we to get a zero here let's just
replace row two with
row
two minus row one so what do we get row
two minus row one row one doesn't change
it's just one one two
three two and then row two minus row one
one minus one is zero
one minus one is zero three minus two is
one
minus three
is minus two four minus two is two
we're almost there we just let's see so
this is a free variable right here this
is a pivot variable right here we have a
one
so let me
get rid of that guy right there and i
can get rid of that guy right there by
replacing row one with row one minus two
times row two so now row two is going to
be the
the same zero zero one
minus two two
and let me replace row 1 with row 1
minus 2 times row 2. so 1 minus 2 times
0 is 1 1 minus 2 times 0 is 1 2 minus 2
times 1 is 0
minus 2 times minus two so that's three
plus four
is seven right where two times this is
minus four we're subtracting it and then
two minus two times two that's two minus
four it's minus two so this is the
reduced row echelon form of b
of b is equal to that right there and
then if i wanted to figure out its null
space
if i want to figure out its null space i
have x1 x2
3 x 4
and x 5
equaling
i'm going to have two zeros right here
now i can just write this as just a set
of system or system of equations
so let me do that i get x one
i get x1 i'm going to write my pivot
variables in a green color x1
plus
1 times x2 so plus x2 plus 0 times x3
plus 7 times x4
minus 2 times x5
is equal to
that 0 right there
and then i get
i get my this is x3 right 0 times x1
plus 0 times x2 plus 1 times x3 so i get
x3
x3 minus 2 times x4 minus 2 times x4
plus 2 times x5
is equal to
that 0 right there and then if we solve
for our pivot variables right these are
our free variables we can set them equal
to anything if we solve for our pivot
variables what do we get
we get x1 is equal to
let me i should do that in green
the color coding helps
i get x1 is equal to
minus x2 minus
x 4 plus 2
x 5 just subtracted these from both
sides of the equation
and i get x 3
is equal to we've done this multiple
times 2 x 4 minus 2x5 and so if i wanted
to write the solution set kind of in
vector form i could write my solution
set is
my solution set or my null space really
is or all the possible x's x1 x2 x3 x4
x5
this this is my vector x that's in an r5
it is equal to
linear combination of these so let me
write it out it's equal to
the free variables are x2 times some
vector
x2 times some vector right there
plus x
well is x3 no x3 is not a free variable
plus x4 that's my next free variable
times some vector
plus x5
times some vector run out of space
plus x5 times some vector and what are
those vectors
let's see
let me let me actually
i don't want to
make this too dirty so let me
see if i can maybe move
nope that's not what i wanted to do
let me just rewrite this
sometimes i haven't mastered this pen
tool yet so let me rewrite this here so
x3 is equal to 2x4 minus 2
x 5. let me delete this right over here
so just so i get some extra space
just cross that out
i think that's good enough so i can go
back to what i was doing before x5 times
some vector right here
and now what are those vectors we just
have to look at these formulas x1 is
equal to -1 times x2 so minus 1 times x2
minus 7 times x4
minus 7 times x4 plus 2 times x5
fair enough and what is x3 equal to
x3 is equal to 2x4
is equal to 2x4
to
x4
right it didn't it had nothing to do
with x2 right here so it's equal to 2x4
minus
minus 2x5 and then what is a and it's a
0 times x2 right because it had no x2
term right here
and then what did what is x2 equal to
well x2 is just equal to 1 times x2 and
so all of these terms are 0 right there
and i want you to pay attention to that
let me write it right here
x2 is a free variable so it's just equal
to itself right 1 and you write a 0 and
a 0. x4 is a free variable
and this is the important point of this
exercise so it's just equal to one times
itself and it doesn't have you don't
have to throw in any of the other free
variables and x5 is a free variable so
just equals one times itself and none of
the other free variables so right here
we now say that all of the solutions of
our of our equation bx equals 0 or the
reduced row echelon form of b times x is
equal to 0 will take this form or there
are linear combinations of these vectors
let's call this v1
v2
and v3 these are just random
numbers random real numbers i can pick
any combination here and to create this
solution set or to create our null space
so our the null space of a which is
equal to
the null space of a which is of course
equal to the null space of the reduced
row echelon form of a
is equal to this all the possible linear
combinations of these three vectors is
equal to the span
of my vector
v1 v2
and
v3
just like that now the whole reason i
went through this exercise because we've
done this multiple times already is to
think about whether these guys form a
linear independent set so my question is
are these guys linearly
linearly
independent and the reason why i care is
because if they are linearly independent
then they form a basis for the null
space right that we know that they span
the null space but if they're linearly
independent then they that's the two
constraints for a basis you have to span
the the the subspace and you have to be
linearly independent so let's just
inspect these guys right here
this v1 he has a 1 right here he has a 1
in the second term because he
corresponds to
x2 to the free variable x2 which is the
second entry so we just threw a 1 here
and we have a 0 everywhere else in all
of the other vectors in our in our
spanning set and that's because for the
other free variables we always wanted to
multiply them times a 0 right and this
is going to be true of any kind of null
space problem we do for any free
variable if this free variable
represents a second entry we're going to
have a 1 in the second entry here and
then a 0 for the second entry for all of
the other
vectors associated with the other free
variables so can this guy ever be
represented as a linear combination of
this guy and that guy well there's
nothing that i can multiply this 0 by
and add to something that i multiplied
this here by to get a 1 here it's just
going to get zeros so this guy can't be
represented as a linear combination of
these guys likewise
this vector right here
has a one in the fourth position why is
it a fourth position because the fourth
position corresponds to its
corresponding free variable x4 so you
this guy's a one here these other guys
will definitely always have a zero here
so you can't take any linear combination
of them to get this guy
so this guy can't represent a linear
combination of those guys and last this
x5 guy right here has a one here and
these guys have zeros here so no linear
combination of these zeros can equal
this one so all of these guys are
linearly independent you can't construct
any of these vectors with some
combination of the other so they are
linearly independent and so this is
actually so v1 the set v1
v2
and v3
is actually a basis
is actually a basis for
the null space
for the null space of oh you know what i
have to be very careful for the null
space of b i defined just for variety i
defined my initial
my initial matrix as matrix b so let me
be very careful here the null space of b
was equal to the null space of the
reduced row echelon form of b
it's good to switch things up every now
you start thinking that every matrix is
named a if you don't and that's equal to
the span of these vectors so these
vectors and we just said that they're
linearly independent we just showed that
because there's no way to get that one
from these guys that one from these guys
or that one from these guys these guys
form a basis for the null space of b
now this raises an interesting question
i in the last video i defined what
dimensionality is and maybe you missed
it because that video is kind of proofy
and you know it but the dimensionality
the dimension
of a subspace of a subspace i'll
redefine it here
is the number of elements
number of elements
in
a basis
for the space for the
subspace
and in the last video i took great
paints to show that all bases for any
given subspace will have the same number
of elements so this is well defined so
my question to you now is
what is
the dimension
of my null space
of b
what is the dimension of my null space
well the dimension is just the number of
vectors in a basis set for b well this
is a basis set for b right there and how
many vectors do i have in it i have one
two three vectors so the dimension of
the null space of b
is three or another way to think about
it or another name for the dimension of
the null space of b is the nullity
the nullity of b
and that is also equal to three and
let's think about it you know i went
through all this exercise but what is
the nullity of any of any matrix going
to be equal to it's the dimension of the
null space well the dimension of the
null space you're always going to have
as many vectors here as you have free
variables
as you have free variables so in general
the nullity
of any met of any matrix of let's say
matrix a
is equal to
the number
of i guess you could call it free
variable columns or the number of free
variables
three variables
in
well i guess we could call it in the
reduced row echelon form of a and the
way or i guess we could say the number
of non-pivot columns i guess is the best
number
of non-pivot
columns
the number of non-pivot columns in the
reduced row echelon form of a because
that's essentially the number of free
variables all of those free variables
have an associated linearly independent
vector with each of them right so the
number of free variables is an is the
number of vectors you're going to have
in your basis for your null space and
the number of free variables is
essentially the number of non-pivot
columns in your reduced row echelon form
right this was a non-pivot column that's
a non-pivot column that's a non-pivot
column and they're associated with the
free variables x2
x4
and x5 so the nullity of a matrix is
essentially the number of non-pivot
columns in the reduced row echelon form
of that matrix anyway hopefully you
found that vaguely useful